what's up kakeland
bunchy okay papi we can do this I mean
I'm a special dancer and I've worked
with a lot of k-pop artists how do we
dance like k-pop stars to me it seems
like 25% purposeful walking and 75%
things I will never be able to do k-pop
artists really have to focus on entire
body lead performance and in unison it
makes a spectacular show for the camera
what kind of dancing background - you
guys have well we just learned Irish
step-dancing
I'm neither Korean nor a dancer yeah
yeah you didn't screwed lap dance the
[ __ ] out of Ned's wife but she's lying
you guys are gonna be performing on the
main floor at the convention yeah yeah
there's gonna be like thousands of
people there guys will all be dancers
kpop artist by the end of today we have
two hours to prepare and we're using
half of that for this interview why are
we talking we got to get to dance they
train so long and hard and cooperating
singing dancing acting and those skills
are required of kpop stars this medley
hits a lot of different variations that
kpop really covers they start with a
boyband XL extra hugs and kisses
step back no it's already hard how I was
going to be forward like I'm hugging key
we need a name for our kpop fan TG TGIF
try guys is fun
grammatically whatever your right leg is
gonna come out clips oh like a horse
what happens next we part each person
plays a different role or position video
TGIF's
later
sort of wrong but okay I gotta tone it
down man we're learning together though
leader it's gonna lead leaders lead you
aren't you a showboating I don't think
people realize how difficult kpop
choreography is their music and dancing
is so syncopated and groups like EXO
they take years of training to perfect
this you guys will be learning a super
girly piece already a better dance I was
important to be a dancer and I'm trying
my best a pretty boy TGIF goes to
everyone's surprise you're gonna go out
yes close yes oh yeah
gotta stay back bro that's my tailor -
I'm not there for you guys I wonder who
it could be
okay girl shake it shake it - kid knows
about sISTAR and love the other girl
groups does that while their music and
choreography is really cute it's also
really sexy and that balance is
extremely difficult to pull off yeah can
we end this song without collapse Big
Bang touched Eugene shoulder there no
I'm hey you're gonna be sexy we're gonna
be cool we're gonna have confidence even
when you're [ __ ] up which we will
yeah bad boy goes to bed yeah we didn't
kpop stars impossible feel like it's a
lot of pressure these guys are under I
believe in these guys I know they can do
this you think a pop ready are we ready
to kill the performance oh my gosh you
guys totally exceeded my expectations
these like super guys they all say do
not be the introduction right we're all
wearing Eugene's clothes because they
said dress like k-pop artists so we
asked Eugene to give us his wardrobe
there was like a brief window of two
seconds where everyone caught a glimpse
of us and they're like and then my
stomach started going nuts
I really have to poop we literally put
this together in one hour we ran it so
much I started forgetting it once you
got into the dance I was had so much
adrenaline here the fuzz applied you
were the closest performance for the
Convention Center at kcon know when told
besides that we walked on stage
we messed a little bit up but people had
fun with us just walking out there the
crowd just screamed bloody murder just
by being beautiful Keith and the rest I
think it's beautiful Keith and the rest
dancing is
this experience isn't really special for
me because when I was growing up Koreans
and Asians were not popular I just want
to thank all the kpop fans out there
you're doing so much for advancing what
people think about Asians and media this
has been really touching that was
incredible international k-pop fans have
the shared notion of kinship the
excitement that people can feel when
they are totally Korean culture is
unique I went from not knowing anything
about Korean culture to feeling like
I've totally been immersed in it
everybody was having such a good time
there's a blast so I think hip hop is
here to stay
for a long time thank you all the fancy
and
let's smell them again